RYAN MATSUMOTO: Today, we're
talking about the Google Cloud
2021 Summit Series and some
exciting news for data lovers.
I'm Ryan, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
The Google Cloud 2021 Summit
Series kicked off last week
with Data Cloud, Financial
Services, and Applied Online
ML.
Up next is the Digital
Manufacturers Summit,
and we've got even more in store
for you throughout the summer.
Be sure to bookmark the
Summit Series website
and register for free today.
We are excited to announce
Dataplex, an intelligent data
fabric that provides a way
to centrally manage, monitor,
and govern your data
across data lakes, data
warehouses, and
data marts and make
this data securely accessible to
a variety of analytics and data
science tools.
Dataplex provides an integrated
analytics experience,
bringing together the best of
Google Cloud and open source
tools so you can rapidly curate,
secure, integrate, and analyze
data at scale.
Dataflow is a no-op, serverless
data processing platform
that enables you to collect and
enrich the vast amounts of data
that your applications
and users generate.
We've built Dataflow Prime to
bring unparalleled resource
utilization and radical
operational simplicity
to big data processing.
Dataflow Prime allows
you to get more done
with less by eliminating the
time you spend sizing resource
needs, optimizing resource
usage to save costs,
and increasing
your productivity.
Check out the
preview in early Q3.
For anyone who's found
sharing and exchanging
data to be a challenge,
we're excited to introduce
Analytics Hub, a new
fully-managed service
available Q3 in
preview that helps
you unlock the value
of data sharing,
leading to new insights and
increased business value.
Check out the blog for a full
list of capabilities today.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see the full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.